اما في العاصمه السعوديه الرياض حيث قالت
وزاره الخارجيه السعوديه ان ممثلين عن
القوات المسلحه السودانيه وقوات الدعم
السريع بداوا السبت محادثات تمهيديه في
جده
واضافت في بيان ان المحادثات تهدف الى وضع
جدول زمني لمفاوضات موسعه تتيح وقفا دائما
للاعمال العدائيه بالسودان كما تهدف الى
تسهيل وصول مساعدات انسانيه طارئه الى
السودان واستعاده الخدمات الاساسيه وقال
بيان الخارجيه السعوديه ان الرياض وواشطه
حفتان طرفين السودانيين على الانخراط
بجديه في المحادثات حتى الطرفين على
الحفاظ على مناخ ايجابي للمحادثات
التمهيديه في جده وكان المتحدث باسم الجيش
السوداني العميد نبيل عبد الله قال
للجزيره ان التفاوض يبحث اليات تمديد
الهدنه ولا يشمل اي اتفاق نهائي لوقف
اطلاق النار او قضايا سياسيه
فيما نقلت وكاله الصحافه الفرنسيه عن
دبلوماسيه سعوديه قوله ان مفاوضات وقف
اطلاق النار في السودان لم تحرز تقدما
كبيرا واضاف دبلوماسيو السعوديه الوقف
الدائم لاطلاق النار ليس مطروحا وان كل
جانب يعتقد انه قادر على حسم المعركه